I remember I was in Italy I saw a
ladybug and I was like this ladybug has
no idea it's Italian find positivity in
any
situation every single person watching
can get happier the superpower
is
relaxation the only Zen you're going to
find at the top of the mountain is the
Zen you bring up there with you we stay
stable not by resisting change but by
changing to not be Patrick Stewart was
such a relief love is woven into every
aspect of Our Lives we need to get
stronger we need to not be afraid of
failure we have to be willing to go
through hardship through suffering
through
pain greetings everybody and uh happy
holidays from everyone here at the RRP
Mothership as it says right here on my
beanie uh this is a time to pause it's a
a time to breathe and perhaps most
importantly a time to reflect something
we're doing today courtesy of part two
of our best of 2023 Anthology which is
essentially a look back at some of the
most impactful conversations of the year
that we've had here and to do that with
gratitude gratitude for of course all
the guests who shared their wisdom
openly with all of us gratitude for my
incredible team gratitude for the quite
enormous growth of the show over the
last 12 months gratitude for the
sponsors that keep the show going but
most of all gratitude to you the
listener truly I do not take your
attention nor your support for granted
and this recap practice is my way of
honoring the magic that we make here
together as well as a reminder of the
power that I think we all have to do and
be better better for ourselves better
for our loved ones and better for the
world so let's kick off this best of
2023 part two with one of my favorite
luminaries expert meditation and
spiritual teacher as well as author of
many transformative books light Watkins
returned in episode 768 where we
discussed meditation we talked about
minimalism but mostly it was a
conversation about living a life of
[Music]
purpose you have everything you need
need to create the life that you
ultimately want right now it's that that
you need more than what you have if
anything it's you need less less
distraction you need less uh temptation
to to use coping mechanisms and things
like that you need less stuff to buy in
order to be fulfilled or happy and so if
you go inside and you start with
cultivating the voice of your inner
guidance and you start listening to that
voice and you start acting upon that
voice that will take you in the
direction of whatever it is that you
envision for yourself you're
not expected to know how it
happens you
just make yourself as loyal as possible
to those little
impulses without any expectation or
anticipation of a specific result and
eventually you will live your way into
that life of your dreams which is going
to come with lots of challenges it's
going to come with you being stretched
out of your comfort zone and into your
potential
and you will look back at those
experiences as the highlights of your
life and those challenging times as
again the good parts of your story
that's what people are going to want to
talk about and it's a real time
um process so it's about really being
process oriented as opposed to outcome
oriented and that's the thing you can
have the most sparse beautiful looking
Zen likee external environment but on
the inside you're still cluttered you're
holding on to toxic relationships you're
maybe holding on to a soul sucking uh
job or a path in your life and if if
you're experiencing all that clutter it
prohibits you from being present with
this beautiful Zen space that you happen
to be in and it's kind of like what
Robert persk the guy who wrote Zen and
the Art of Motorcycle M and said you the
only Zen you're going to find at the top
of the mountain this is in you bring up
there with you m you know so it's like
that every space you enter every
relationship you enter any
accomplishment you have you're going to
bring all the happiness that you're
going to get from that with you to the
relationship to the space to the
accomplishment right and um Everybody
ultimately no matter what you do in your
life everybody ultimately wants to be
fulfilled right
so what is how do you get to be
fulfilled well that's where people you
know have different ideas some people
think it's because it's from
accomplishments or it's from money or
it's from you know some other external
circumstance but
really what brings fulfillment is living
a purposeful life right living a I was
listening to a this other podcast
interview and this guy was helping
people get out of prison and he said
there's no drug I've ever taken that
gives me the same high as helping these
these these inmates who were innocent
get freed from prison and you know if
you're being of service or if you're
raising a family and that's what you've
identifyed with as your purpose or if
you're doing something else that's
related to your heart then you're
experiencing some degree of fulfillment
that you would not be experiencing
otherwise and really the only way to to
know that is to have the experience so
then how do you lead a purposeful life
well a lot of people are confused about
you know I don't know what my purpose
purp is I write about purpose a lot and
I get a lot of replies I don't I don't
you know I feel like I don't live that
purposeful life and so I say you have to
follow curiosity you don't worry about
trying to find your purpose just follow
curiosity and your purpose will find you
well how do you follow your curiosity
well your curiosity is going to have you
doing things that are going to make you
look foolish probably and it's not going
to be practical and it's not going to
make a lot of sense to the people around
you so you have to be okay with that and
the only way to be okay with that is to
feel so
um called by your purpose by by your
curiosity that you're willing to do it
anyway and what stands in between you
being able to do that follow the
Curiosity with with with the fomo right
fear of other people's opinions Foo fear
of other people's opinions in full play
is you have to get rid of the stuff that
keeps you Shackled to those opinions
which is some degree of stress right cuz
stress when you're tired stress makes
you tired stress makes you anxious
stress makes you
um f future thinking or you you're
focused on a past regret it's hard to
follow your curiosity when you have
those things playing out in the back of
your awareness what is the process like
how would you like if if I just said
that to you when I was your student and
you your meditation student like walk me
through how you would untangle that knot
and you know get me into a place where I
could hear the voice of my own innate
curiosity so that voice is in there we
usually refer to it as the still Small
Voice like those internal nudging those
hunches saying hey maybe go left instead
of going right on your commute today
just see what happens or hey go and
compliment that person on their nice
shoes or hey um stay at home today and
and just read a book you know these
kinds of things and so that voice is in
there it's a still Small
Voice and we had it when we were kids
everybody has it as a kid you know you
see kids they can play with a stick for
hours or they can just go out and
imagine things and make believe and
there's something that happens once you
start getting schooled is you get
indoctrinated to believe what success is
supposed to look like which is being
disciplined being responsible achieving
things getting married you know having a
good job etc etc and then that becomes
the primary focus and then the voice of
curiosity or the still Small Voice gets
filed away in the extracurricular
activity um folder where if you have
enough time when you're not being
responsible and you know working on your
job or your whatever then you can play
around with that on the weekends and
actually it's the opposite we should be
prioritizing that voice because that
voice is keeping us on track back with
whatever it is that our purpose or our
passion uh truly is in this lifetime
which no one can tell you what that is
no one can you can't go to anyone you
can't go to me you can't go to any
psychic or therapist and they can sit
you down and say your purpose is to dot
dot dot only you know what that is but
you have to get conversational in the
language of that internal
Voice next up is 2021 Facebook
whistleblower Francis hgan who joined me
back in episode
779 to explain the nuanced impact of
social media on society as well as why
algorithms prioritize extreme content
and the tools available to us to combat
these important and admittedly at times
terrifying
issues as a data scientist a lot of
people you hear a lot of people saying
well we don't even know how these
algorithms work like what parts of it do
you understand and which parts of it
elude even someone like yourself so it's
one of these things where you know um
this is a very young field like this is
one of these things where I talk about
in the book and and we can design a
system and say this is the data we put
into it like we can we can describe that
we can see it we can you know when Elon
published the algorithm like he can see
what Provisions it says but the problem
is that all these things work together
in ways that are unexpected like no one
have fac when they made the shift from
saying can we keep you on the platform
as long as possible to can we get you to
react as much as possible no one said I
think this is going to lead to more
extreme content like no one no one's set
out to do that and and I I I want to
validate the things that Facebook has
said you know they say we don't
recognize these allegations we would
never intend to do that I don't think
they did but the problem is that when
they learned there were these side
effects and and and right now the only
people who get to ask questions about
could there be side effects are the
people inside the companies um you know
people who have a vested interest in not
knowing you know when they learned that
there were these consequences um and and
to be clear like the the shift was big
enough that like the CEO of BuzzFeed
wrote to Facebook and said I think
something's broken Jonah Paretti um I
don't I I don't remember which which
gener it was would have been in like
2018 or 2019 so I don't know which which
era that is yeah that's it's it's wild
yeah and it's getting Wilder right like
when we think about um what went down in
terms of election interference in 2016
and in 2020 yeah it feels kind of very
you know kind of not that big of a deal
in consideration with what we're
contending with as we as we you know
Kine towards the 2024 election um
everything is now suddenly infinitely
more are complicated due to the release
of these various llms the rapid growth
of generative AI deep fake technology
like the tools that are now available on
the disinformation battlefield are just
extraordinarily powerful so how do you
think about how those tools are going to
be deployed and what we can expect as we
you know move towards November so I
think there's there's two areas that we
we need to really pay mention to so so
one is um you know when Mark Zuckerberg
excuse me when Elon Musk fired a lot of
his safety teams it really shifted the
information environment so one of my um
uh my husband and I like to watch
YouTube together because we're nerdy and
there's a guy named Peter zand who
follows a lot of the politics in Russia
and you know he was talking about how it
used to be his one of his best data
sources was Twitter and when Elon came
in he ended up blocking a lot of people
who were in in Russia but he also um
like because he fired the teams that
were looking for the coordinated
Behavior you can really obviously tell
the trolls on both sides of the conflict
now just outweigh the real voices and so
one is we are investing Less in Catching
Bad actors but the second is the way the
tools have changed what's even possible
with misinformation so for for context
for people one of the ways we used to
catch those Bots or like catch the
networks people who were pushing an
information operation was we look for
repetition so you know there's always
this interesting trade-off between how
much distribution can you do and how
much unique content can you do right so
if you you really don't want to get
caught you write a different thing every
time before the large language models
came out you you were limited you know
you you weren't going to reach a ton of
people if every single thing you posted
was unique so you could start looking
and saying interesting you keep sharing
the same links or or this group of
people keeps saying very very similar
things or maybe even the same thing
right and it becomes clear that this is
a bot farm right um or like China was
particularly egregious at this because
they would do things like they would
have brigades of tens of thousands of
people who would just like flood the
common threads on dissident posts with
like just the Chinese flag you know like
like you can tell this is all the same
thing um when you start having large
language models it's now possible to go
and generate tens of thousands of unique
pieces of content that all basically say
the same thing but say it in slightly
different ways um and that makes it a
lot harder to see that coordination or
for example you know um part of what
makes misinformation so
pernicious is consensus reality is like
a channel you know there's there's not
like a huge Continuum of what you can
talk about there's like you know we can
sit and come to a view of like reality
if we talk long enough um when it comes
to misinformation it can play in the
entire field of ideas and whatever is
like the most seductive or like uh most
incendiary on the algorithm that's the
thing that gets distributed in a world
with large language models you can
generate 10,000 different variations and
send them to lots of different nooks and
figure out what meme like what idea is
most seductive and that that just
supercharges what can be done with a
misinformation campaign it's terrifying
it is and that that doesn't even get
into all the Deep fake stuff when you
can mock somebody's voice or their
likeness in a compelling way that's
indistinguishable from reality then our
footing in what is real and what isn't
real vanishes and things get really
scary um it's we are living and and this
is part of why we have to start having
more transparency because we have tools
where we can start saying hey we got we
got to move this ball down the field um
but there is no economic incentive today
to do those things on their own so what
are we going to do Francis like what's
the solution here how do we how do we
put a better foot forward so part of I
think the first step is is is just and
this is a big part about why I wrote the
book like I'm I think of the things that
I regret the most about the ru out of my
book is is no conservative media has has
offered to like talk to me right like I
haven't been on Fox News I haven't uh
we've reached out to a number of of I
would think they happy to talk to you I
would think so because like I've been
saying consistently since the beginning
you know content moderation is a flat
strategy but Facebook spent a huge sum
of money on a whisper campaign saying
you know she's a dark horse for
censorship um and so I think the place
we start from is an idea that people
have the right to see how these systems
work right like I should have the right
to know I am not allowed to sell my book
on Facebook right we the public should
be able to see what content gets taken
down right now the only avenues that we
have are you can appeal to the Facebook
oversight board but it disappears into a
black hole right um things can really
change if we have transparency and and
and so we need to First work on how do
we make that a bipartisan issue that we
cannot have an information environment
that is run by a private company in the
dark and have a democracy and the second
thing is like so how might we actually
do that so um uh Europe passed a law
called the Digital Services act last
year um I talk about in the book um that
basically it it sounds it sounds pretty
blah it's like you know if you know
there's a risk to your platform you got
to tell us about it like we know you get
to operate behind the curtain but we
can't see we'll never catch up with you
unless you tell us what you already know
you have to tell us what your plan is
for reducing that risk and you need to
give us enough data that we can see that
you're making progress and if we ask you
a question you have to give us an answer
and if we don't comply so it's I think
it's like 10% of global revenues oh wow
the penalty it's that's for real real A
real one though when you have a 35%
profit margin it's possible Facebook
would come out and say we are now 25% a
business expense business
[Music]
expense Relentless experimentor and
master of podcasting and productivity
Tim Ferris joined me for a rather
vulnerable exchange on how he grapples
with anxiety and depression we talked
about how to face difficult emotions and
the various modalities that he's
explored from silent meditation to
psychotherapy including some grounded
thoughts on his experiences with
psychedelics you know maybe we can spend
a couple minutes on some of the more
helpful
resources um like we talked about
they're all on your blog um but there's
there's a quote that kind of recurs that
I've heard you say a couple times it to
me it almost acts like a Talisman or or
way into this process and I believe it's
Tara Brock who said it focusing on like
or thinking about what it is that you're
unwilling to feel yeah right like as a
as a that that like really kind of like
pulls focus on totally where to begin
yeah the teror Brock and I really
recommend I'm actually rereading it
right now radical acceptance some of you
may may find that a bit nauseating in
title and I also was sort of repelled by
this very generic title but it was
recommended to me by uh PhD and
Neuroscience who is not in the woo camp
at all and I read it many years ago and
I found it so helpful and I've been
recommending it and recommending it and
recommending it and I recommended
someone a week I like you know what
maybe maybe it's time for me to reread
that so I dug back into it and I think
it is in radical acceptance Tera Brock B
R I think it is in that book maybe at
the head of one of the chapters where
she says a wise Sage once said there is
only one question that really matters
what is it that you are unwilling to
feel that is a very focusing question uh
so that is a good place to start I'm a
journaling junkie I really find that it
is difficult to think clearly or to even
learn what you think without trapping it
on paper so you can of
examine the thoughts they're very
difficult to capture or cross-examine
without putting them on paper morning
pages I find very very helpful for this
so in terms of tools and feel free to to
direct me in any way that you'd like but
in terms of just a handful of tools
there are ongoing tools and then there
inputs in the form of books I would say
there are few that have really impacted
me already mentioned radical acceptance
so I would put that pretty high on the
list another book which is shorter and
easier to complete but that many people
find super abrasive is a book called
awareness by Anthony Dello it's a short
book it's mostly a clean up transcript
of public lectures that he gave Jesuit
priest and psychotherapist who is who is
since past he has a very nobs M approach
to things which some people find very
offensive I like that kind of tough love
coach type Vibe so it works for
me
the waking up app introductory course I
think for people who have never
meditated who have the opinion which I
did for a very long time it just ain't
for me sitting still hum hum hum
whatever you do I don't think I can do
that my mind's all over the place the
waking up app introductory course
presents a logical sequence of skill
development that is what makes it I
think unique and very appealing it's 10
minutes each morning and do it for a
month your life I think will change your
awareness of the scripts that are
running your life will become more
acute and then I would say focusing on
sleep first and foremost and I've had
you know a number of chats with Matt
Walker of UC
F on my podcast really focusing on sleep
since I've had lifelong issues with
insomnia onset insomnia specifically Tim
on consistent good sleep for even 3 days
and Tim on mediocre sleep for 3 Days
those are two different Tims so really
making the compromises necessary taking
the actions necessary for instance like
Zone 2 or higher level aerobic training
which historically I hate I hate it with
a passion I would much rather go into
the gym and do sets of five with heavier
weights I hate aerobic exercise
generally however I found a few that
seem to a dramatically improve my mood
and really help me sleep for whatever
set of reasons and then we can talk
about perhaps the the one that I've been
not so defly maybe super obviously
navigating around which is psychedelic
assisted therapy that that is the
amplifier that is the tool that has
allowed me most
consistently to take an
observer seat where I can look at the
beliefs and
behaviors that I take for granted that
are automatic that I think are
unavoidable or that I don't think about
at all that are dictating the quality of
my life or the self-punishment that I'm
inflicting author Shu PL based cheese
founder and my in-house Oracle and
better half Julie Patt joined me on
episode 791 dropping wisdom on finding
Enlightenment honoring your physical
form and the beauty that comes from
embodying
self-love I recently heard somebody
raving about oh you know there's this
enlightened being and he's made it
through the 12 stages of Enlightenment
you know and I just sort of smiled I
mean you know I'm sure the being is very
amazing and very beautiful but it's all
a system it's all a perspective it's
just a fractal it's a perspective of the
crystal of which we all make up we we
all come from that and so the other
thing that I would like to just offer
you as your beloved and as um someone
who uh cares for you deeply and and I
know that we we share this you say this
self-love part is so tough for you well
it's tough for all of us I mean that is
the thing I mean you can talk to Jazelle
who's like the most beautiful supermodel
ever and she'll tell you that she felt
ugly judged I mean I don't know her so
Jazelle I don't know if that you really
said that but I'm just I'm going to I'm
going to wager that that's true it
doesn't matter it's like it's part of
the human condition because we leave the
one and we come into a body and we feel
this immense separation and with that
separation comes this you know falling
from from the unity basically so it's by
design that it happens that way but what
I would offer to you is that I'm
starting to think that it's not going to
be hard at all actually um I've had a
couple um experiences in the last few
months where I've I've glimpsed aspects
of being embodied in uh let's say a more
High vibrating life form like in my body
and and so you know as we're you know
we're you know I'm doing Pilates or you
know I'm taking care of my skin or I'm
making sure that I hike and that I
meditate and that you know I don't carry
stress in my body um you know I'm think
you know I'm feeling like you know I I
want to take care of my physical form
and I had this moment where this sort of
quantum uh presence came into my body
and showed
me just a glimpse of the power the
Perfection the beauty that is just there
Beyond this density and then I started
laughing and I said actually I don't
maybe it's not going to be hard at all
maybe when the frequency gets to that
point it's going to be like the wind
blows across your cheek and suddenly
you're rejuvenated you know your back is
feeling better like we're you know so
again it's like this idea of hard work
is old in a lot of ways old Paradigm it
shouldn't be hard work I am not
disciplined I'm not working hard at
spirituality I am in a state of
beingness of connection to the breath
the moment the presence the allowing the
surrender and The Greatest Secret that I
can share on your show today and right
now in my life the superpower
is
relaxation that is the superpower so
everyone listening to this just consider
how you are when you're working so hard
you're going for things so you know
committed you're you're wanting this so
badly it's like just observe all the
things in your body that are
constricting it's closing off your life
force it's it's causing a closing down
of energy and what if you knew that the
more you could relax just everybody just
let your belly go let your body just
relax start to connect to your breath
and what if you knew that the more you
relaxed the more light could enter you
the more help you can get from the
universe the more you merge with that
which is really sourcing you living you
breathing you so this whole idea of this
work you know we got to work and it's
got to be so hard doesn't it's actually
not true it's an illusion so again many
years ago when your beloved friend who
was on the cover of Time Magazine The
Olympian the swimmer he's a reverend um
Byron Davis yeah Byron Davis he was
sitting at our kitchen table and you
guys were having this conversation we
were having this conversation and I was
like how about training for the love of
it like Just For the Love of it and he
told this story he was training for a
qualifying round or something and he
woke up with the flu and he was not in
his best self and he was swimming and
he's and he was getting beat and then
suddenly he said something Beyond
himself came in and he entered this
relaxation and he
won and we had that conversation back
then so it's not it's not foreign to you
I know that but I'm reminding
you and I'm not saying so then don't say
that oh well then how does anything get
done you know I do 29 things all the
time it's it's the way it's done it's
the intention that it's done in and so
this world is a beautiful world where we
get to evolve through
experiences and that's why every single
one of your desires you should
experience it you should do it you
should go for it Go in it feel it you
know be it become it because that's
Evolution and that's what we're here
for so much more on its way but first a
quick word from our partners who to make
the show
[Music]
possible director of nutrition studies
at the Stanford University prevention
Research Center Dr Christopher Gardner
joined me to share an evidence-based
rational model for Nutritional Health as
well as a discussion about how to
distinguish good nutrition science from
bat here's an excerpt from that
conversation
[Music]
uh the American Heart Association has
regularly for 50 years updated their
dietary guidelines and the previous most
recent update was 2006 and in 2021 they
did it again didn't honestly change all
that much but they refined a few things
and they spent a ton of time in this
paper looking at all the literature that
was available before 2006 and between
2006 and
2021 here's all the data we have on who
has a heart attack my Cardin fuction
stroke any kind of cardiovascular
disease here's 10
domains that cover a heart healthy
diet and and those are sort of
individual things about whole grains and
veggies and beans and salt and saturated
fat and they said here's the things to
include or avoid and then the public
said so does what does that mean should
I be vegan or should I be Mediterranean
or should I be paleo they said ah you
know we should do another paper on
patterns so instead of individual
components how many of these popular
dietary patterns out there could be
consistent with this set of domains in
other words like the overlap in the VIN
diagram between all of these different
perspectives and so I want to focus on
the overlap at first so the 10 patterns
we picked were the dash uh diet that's
the dietary approaches to stop
hypertension
Mediterranean three types of of
vegetarians who had PESA we had the ovol
lacto vegetarian we had vegan sort of a
higher fat vegan we ALS also had a
really lowfat vegan diet we had a low
carb a lowf fat a Paleo and a keto I
hope that was 10 because we had 10
patterns and we tried to match them up
to the 10 domains and we scored them
from high to low and dash and
Mediterranean got the best score and
paleo and keto got the worst score as
you were matching these domains and
happy to go into some of those details
if you want but one of my takeaways that
I thought was great was a cross all 10
they all said more vegetables more Whole
Foods less added sugar and less refined
grain across all 10 now this could be a
trivial response if those are things we
already did those are four of the
biggest problems with the US diet we
don't eat many vegetables we eat a lot
of ultra processed food we eat a crap
ton of added sugar and a crap ton of
refined grain so for for me this is a
Kumbaya moment oh my God all the
patterns agree on 50% % of probably what
plagues human health associated with
diet why don't we all get together and
work on that that's no
fun ah yes it's not as the clickbait
doesn't work but we really all agree on
those and those are all big issues the
one extra one I'd love to add in there
is beans I actually think eating more
beans is probably the biggest thing
Americans could do to change their diet
in a positive way and there's so many
kinds of beans
culturally appropriate lotss of
unapologetically delicious dishes with
lentils and chickpeas and kidney beans
and refried beans oh my god um but you
wouldn't get the Paleo and keto in there
right because they're they're super low
carb and beans are full of carbs so if
you after the the four things I
mentioned first that they all agree on
the next ones I would add would be
beans come next yeah I mean I like that
way of looking at it like this heat map
sort of um perspective that allows you
to transcend all the labels and the
tribalism and all of that and really
just focus on you know this is I think
you've characterized this as being like
50% of the but it's it's kind of like 90
90% isn't it I mean it's really like if
you do those four things and then maybe
the fifth with the beans like you're on
the five yard line pretty much right and
and so and another way to appreciate uh
yeah acknowledge that appreciate it is I
do think there are Arguments for some of
these low carb low fat high protein
individual and when the margin the
margins after you got the foundation
right so there'd be a lot less bickering
if yeah I do all these things and huh
and I actually prefer avocado to steel
cut oats or something I I I prefer this
higher protein to this higher carb
whatever yeah I think you could hedge
your bets and at that point sort of
biohack your own metabolism and come up
with something that's a little better
for you than the other thing but can you
please fix the first 50 or 90% because
we all agree on that and you're doing
that wrong right so this first tier of
the heat map less added sugar less
refined grains way more starchy veg more
Whole Foods less Ultra processed foods
and then with a foot note around beans
but then there's a tier just below this
right okay we've done that now how do we
get to the next level fli that one
little thing you said starchy veg so the
one things they all agree on is non
starchy V that's what I meant to say
sorry about broccol cauliflower leafy
greens red bell peppers um but then then
you get to the the avocado the avocados
the nuts the seeds the olive oil fruits
or we can eat fish or we can eat eggs
like that kind of all falls into that
next tier you're talking about this this
core that has a second ring and my
second ring is beans oh my god with
lectin fruits oh my God they have sugar
nuts oh my God they have fat eggs oh my
God they have cholesterol fish oh my God
they have a face you know at that at
that second level the lectin don't
matter the sugar and fruits is fine it's
in the fruit Matrix the nuts have
unsaturated fat so that next tier of
foods is pretty good mhm um but it's at
the margin after you deal with that
thing in the middle and let's assume we
now mastered this tier okay what comes
next where are we going to we're going
to go behind the Velvet Rope and you
know put the cherry on top of the Sunday
yeah so to be honest Americans eat too
much wheat they eat eat too much grain
they even eat too much whole grain bread
so glycemic index is how fast the
glucose from the food you're eating ends
up in your blood and a shocking thing
for people who read into this and look
it up is that white flower bread and
whole weed Bread have the same glycemic
index it's like wait very high high
glycemic index is not good I I switched
from white flour the whole wheat flour
how why wasn't that better and the
reason it wasn't better is because it
was ground to a powder and most of the
digestion was done so the time it takes
you to eat it and absorb it is really
small if you had used the whole grain
which is the wheat berry it would have
taken much longer for your enzymes to
digest it and make the molecules small
enough to absorb so you were saying go
to the next level of these concentric
rings so grains so a funny thing that I
learned from doing some studies related
to protein and trying to figure out
where our protein comes from is looking
at the
usda's fabulous website of all the food
we produce and what we eat and under
grains it's said okay grains include
oats and barley and wheat and this other
thing but because American
uh 90% of the grains that eat are wheat
we're simply using the value for wheat
for this thing that we're analyzing and
I stopped for a moment I said really has
all these grains out there and 90% of
what Americans eat is
wheat and most of that is bread right
pizza crust Donuts uh you know some kind
of bread-like thing so at that next
level I think is grains so I've actually
I hosted a debate one time between
uh a Paleo person and a Mediterranean
person and a middle- of the road person
and I tried to force them to say what do
you agree on I know you guys disagree on
some things what do you agree on and the
first thing I got them all to agree on
that people didn't expect was grains
even like the vegan person said uh yeah
if I was going to get rid of anything
next it would be grains because so much
of it is refined even even the whole
grain
bread
your darkest moments will either break
you beyond repair or they're going to
make you stronger well this was the
choice faced by Steph kud doll as her
husband beloved ultr Runner Tommy rivs
battled a very rare form of cancer that
nearly took his life Steph joined me in
episode 787 to discuss the big things in
life trauma mortality love grief and
meaning all of which are beautifully
explored in her Memo are everything all
at
once if you coign to the idea that all
of us have capacity and potential that
we're walking around with that we're
just not aware of or yeah uh we haven't
really you know brought forth in our own
lives um do we really need to be in that
kind of a tragic event or to suffer yeah
extreme pain in order to manifest it
yeah it's a choice yeah it just rarely
happens short of you know basically
being boxed into a corner in that kind
of a way yeah well similarly ribs and I
are for lack of a better word happier
together than we've ever been and people
are like how are you so happy I'm like
uh just make him almost die and then
you'll you know what I mean you'll go
through together this recognition of how
much you love each other and how
important you are to each other and
things that we take for granted that are
sometimes only shown to us in the depths
of Despair sadly how do you access that
feeling of gratitude and awareness when
you're not in the depths and I'm
struggling with that now even please
tell me how to do that yeah right oh you
don't know oh cuz I I'm now even I want
to maintain the lessons I learned be
present there's no better moment than
this moment right now and all the love
you ever need is inside of you all of
these truths I know them but it's harder
to feel them when life is good what I
learned and what I'm learning is that
memory are memory is the the cursor to
things that are always happening these
memories are actually ever present and
and we can access them and go back to
that time in a in a moment well they're
they're consciously or unconsciously
impacting every decision that we make so
they do live in the present they do
absolutely and um I mean the most the
like the the starkest example of this
was when rivs was at the end of his life
and I went in there to say goodbye is
what they told me to do and I rested my
head on his chest and in a moment we
were dancing together and we were living
that moment together in the present and
nobody could tell me that didn't happen
that I was not metaphysically there cuz
I was my body was here but I was there
with him and we were dancing together
and that that that memory I feel Drew us
back together into this world and and
called him back to this life and I think
that example was why I wanted to
weave the malleability of time into into
my whole book um because I realized that
it was memory that was saving me over
and over again mostly the memory of love
and and that's what I feel kept me my
whole life from going over the edge
these these everpresent
moments of presence um that I was called
back to and um and on the other hand
rivs he lived lifetimes in his coma he
was I mean he has some incredible
stories about where he was and where he
went and how many different families he
had and and who's to say that those
weren't real that those weren't really
occurring lives you know I'm not I would
never say he says some of those memories
of when he was in the coma feel more
real than this life memory you know wow
so I'm really really interested in the
quantum aspect that I don't I wish I
understood on a physics level yeah um
but I all I know is my experience with
with time and um yeah so what do we take
from that how are we supposed to
interpret that or how is that meant to
from your perspective inform Our Lives I
mean really it's that love is woven into
every aspect of our lives in in the form
of
memory um and that in the most tragic
Moments Love or the memory of Love is
still there and I like to think of my
father whether he exists in a spiritual
realm or just in a memory I think that
the memory of his love
is the same as thing that he lives in
some spirit world and that that love is
entwined in in every aspect of my life
and um and it's in all of our lives and
if what one of the most pivotal moments
of of my um life today was recognizing
how that love had been in in everything
absolutely everything when I was drunk
crying under a table when I was
hitchhiking through Guatemala when I was
you know everything that I did love was
there I just I just didn't recognize it
in myself so I couldn't recognize it in
other
[Music]
people up next is serial entrepreneur
and the host of The United Kingdom's
number one podcast Diary of a CEO Steven
Bartlett who shared some really great
wisdom on how to hone discipline and
balance ambition with
self-care
In This Moment how I'm feeling is I feel
like I've overextended myself in my life
I feel like 12 months ago or 6 months
ago I must have said yes to too many
things and not have been cognizant of
the nature of my the fact that my time
is finite and this is a constant battle
I have in my life which is my ambition
is maybe exceeding my
capacity um which I need to put into
check because I pay the price for that I
end up having letting someone down
somewhere and also therefore myself in
the process and right now where I'm at
I've definitely taken on too much stuff
mhm so endurance is great what we need
is consistency and sustainability we
don't need intensity intensity is may be
useful in in spurts but you can't
maintains intensity for a consistent
enduring period of time nobody can
without something Falling by the wayside
that matters and I the frame I try and
apply to the decisions when I see
something on my list a request that
comes in is how would I feel feel if I
had to do that tomorrow and that's the
frame I should be applying which is how
would I feel if I had to do that later
on today or tomorrow because I fall
under the same bias which is I defer it
to a future Steve who I can't yet
understand the circumstances of the day
that he's currently in and by bringing
it to today's Steve it kind of helps me
filter out things against my values and
intentions um and that whole frame
generally I was talking about this last
night to one of my friends of really
being cognizant that when you wake up
every day
after spending eight of your as I talk
about my first book proverbial chips on
sleep you have these 16 chips left and
how you place those 16 chips on the
roulette table of life is the center
point of your influence on your own life
the allocation of those 16 chips on this
proverbial roulette table of life and
when the the wheel spins every day you
find out the returns you've got so these
16 chips how do I place them and what
are my values and you're trying to place
them where your values are and if you if
you land on your values you get great
returns so placing two against spending
time with my girlfriend in the evening
placing four against my podcast four
against my businesses two against DJing
one against Jim that's a that's time
I'll spent and I might also it's
important to say this I might Place one
against binging Netflix if it was
intentional it's not wasted time it's
only wasted time in my regard when you
you didn't do it consciously and
intentionally um and that framework is
so important because if you look at
anyone's how we allocate our time it's
so clear we think we're live forever
it's why on all of my desks on my
bookshelf behind me on the Diary of a CO
I have this sandtimer because I don't
believe humans can imagine in INF infiny
or finality I don't think we're capable
of such a thing so we we allocate our
time in um trivial regrettable ways but
our time is literally the currency we
have the allocation of my time up until
this moment where I'm sat with you today
is the thing that has put me in this
chair today it's like well allocated
time in my regard because managed to get
you know to have a conversation with you
so thinking through that Tech that
framework and reminding myself that you
know time is so so precious and so
finite um allows you to hopefully make
decisions about you what you're doing
with your day that are unregrettable
which is my goal at the moment yeah I
think it it requires or it it Demands a
certain um type of discipline that might
not be immediately obvious because when
we think about discipline we think about
you know how hard can we work or how can
we make that hard choice to delay
gratification but discipline comes in
many forms I think the chapter in the
new book about discipline you come up
with this equation right about that
which kind of speaks to uh you know what
you just mentioned I actually the title
of that law in my book was about time it
was about time management I started out
to write about time management because
everyone wants time management
techniques and as I go down there and as
I start doing my research on time
management techniques I discover there
are
hundreds right and I also if I'm honest
with myself there's none that I use so I
asked myself why and in the same way
that there's lots of fad diets um out
there the reason why there's so many
time management techniques is because
none of them fundamentally work so
people keep going in search of new ones
and creating new ones because they lack
the fundamental um skill of discipline
so I asked myself okay um why does
discipline matter well in a world where
time is finite as we've just discussed
you can only do so many things and so I
try and figure out why in some areas of
my life I've been disciplined with the
gym six seven days a week with DJing
with my businesses and why in other
areas of my life has my discipline
lapsed so I tried to write a simple
equation um which is and i' would love
to you to interrogate this with me
because I'm still you know trying to
refine the equation but at the start of
the equation you have in simple terms um
why does the goal matter to you right
Plus the psychological enjoyment you get
in the pursuit of the goal minus let's
call it the psychological um
disengagement or the psychological
friction associated with the goal so
with going to the gym I started going in
the on March 2020 and I've been going
for over three years now March 2020 I
watched a pandemic sweep the world and I
watched through my TV screen people
dying because of Health um uh Health
their health circumstances and the
correlation between outcomes and Health
circumstance it was so traumatic to me
that it in increased my why to to so
much so that the Habit stuck and I was
so clear to me now that the foundation
of all my goals my businesses my
girlfriend my relationship my dog my
family was my health I saw the tectonic
plate Shake underneath everything I care
about um The Pursuit itself of going to
the gym is psychologically enjoyable as
long as the gym is close and as long as
um it's private so I'm not spending a
lot of time just talking about the
podcast with people um minus the
friction Associated to it so reducing
the friction means me finding a private
gym I actually stopped going to the gym
when my when people knew who I was
because I people came up to me a lot the
friction increased and Simon sinic
challenged this the other day with me
and he goes well you know like I get up
every morning and I go and empty the bin
outside my house because he goes I don't
enjoy that and it's not meaningful to me
I go yeah but it is Simon because what
happens if you so if we examine that
through that framework what happens if
you don't empty the bin outside your
house Simon well you're going to get
fined and it's going to overflow for the
whole week so your wire is actually
pretty high the psychological enjoyment
is low sorry the the enjoyment is low
and the friction is high but the Y is
higher than the friction is getting out
of better a. it matters more to you the
why the pursuit you know achieving that
goal than the um friction is
unmotivating for you if some point they
reduced the why so you would no longer
get fines and you had a second bin you
wouldn't get out of bed the friction
would win out and so the reason it's
important to think through that
framework is you can influence it if if
there's something in your life where
you're not disciplined you can focus on
those first that first half of the
equation remind yourself why this really
really matters to you and then do
everything you can to make the pursuit
of the goal as enjoyable and as engaging
as you
[Music]
can what do you do when you have two
very different dreams vying for your
attention well this is the Dilemma faced
by five-time world champion professional
triathlete and the Oscar nominated
screenwriter of last year's Best Picture
Winner All Quiet on the Western Front
her name is Leslie Patterson and here
she shares some wisdom gold from that
exchange my whole life like there's
athletes and there's artists right and
never the twain shall meet these are
people who are configured differently
yep and you it's up to you to figure out
which one of those two if you're
interested in both you kind of have to
pick one totally and nobody's gonna tell
you that it's cool to do both no
absolutely and and you're kind of like
an outlier in both right so you know as
an athlete you're you're you know
everyone makes fun of the artists and
they have a completely different time
clock they stay up all night they smoke
they don't care take care of their
bodies they have they cannot understand
the athlete um and then equally you know
um the the the that the artist is like
you know they have no sense of the
athlete what that's like you know
neither Camp can truly understand and
yet I feel like there's so much
similarity and there's so much you can
draw down from from each from each craft
so what would be some of those things so
I think the main thing is the
discipline that I learned from
sport H really help help the creativity
CU as ethereal is being creative and
when is that good idea going to come if
you still give yourself some sense of
structure then you're working towards
something and certainly when it comes to
to screenplay writing right there's a
lot of structure it's almost
like if you know the structure enough
then you can let it go and it becomes
intuitive and that's the same in sport
if you train enough to push yourself to
the limits enough then in the race
you'll find your zone so it's kind of
like the same um and then equally I
think in sport if you really want to get
to the top you have to be creative you
have to think outside the box about how
you're going to push your mind and your
body to truly achieve greatness and you
know I went down a lot of systems in
sport you know a lot of national bodies
a British national body and certainly
this was back kind of in the '90s and
the early 2000s when they weren't as
developed as they are now but but it was
so it was like okay there's one way to
do this and if you're not good at this
one way then you're never going to be a
world champion and I wasn't good at that
one way and I'm like well yeah but I
still think I could be good MH um so the
creativity allowed me to investigate so
many other ways and I love it cuz my
husband Simon says it's it's you know a
cargo net it's not a
ladder to the top explained that it's a
cargo net cargo net means there's many
different ways to the top a ladder
there's one
one um yeah and that's that's kind of a
beautiful analogy CU that's how I think
I've gotten to the top and both is just
kind of like really going to the side
and up and down and up and to the side
and across and and being at peace with
that um as well which has taken time
right because you are an outlier and you
are bucking the system and as a result
there will be push back or resistance or
criticism for trying to find a different
way oh yeah yeah all the time yeah and I
I think it it it it puts the lie to the
test this notion that the artist is
struck with inspiration after you know a
pack of cigarettes and a bottle of you
know bourbon at 3:00 a.m and and and you
know helps one to realize and this is a
very kind of Steven
pressfield um Seth Goen kind of thing
that that creativity is a discipline in
the same way the pursuit of excellent in
sport is it requires rigor and structure
accountability and all of those things
you have to create those structures in
order to make space for the creativity
to appear exactly you know in that idea
of like you know the war the war of art
or turning pro like are you a
professional like if you're a
professional creative then you show up
for it every day in the same way you
show up for practice for your sport you
can't say I have writer block is that
would be like saying you know I I I have
I have sport block today like I'm not
going you know I'm not gonna show up for
practice but equally it's like even if
you do have some kind of block or you're
not making the forward momentum that you
want to it's saying how can I get a
positive result today what does that
mean what does that look like and having
again that's that cargo net analogy
where you know what you deem to be
successful on any given day you know is
is different for every individual but
certainly for me in sport right I would
have many shitty days I mean any top
athlete will tell you that many many
shitty days I've dealt with Lyme disease
chronic injuries so how can you find
something positive that you can still
make a step forward in some capacity
whether that's mentally or physically
and similarly you know on the on the art
front on storytelling front on script
writing front you know it's
understanding how your brain works what
suits you what doesn't how to still find
kind some kind of momentum
even when you're having a bad day um and
maybe that's I'm I'm such a positive
person I love to find the positivity in
anything and I don't know if that's
because I grew up you know my dad's
pretty pretty tough Scottish man you
know nothing is ever going to impress
him however it has now I'm getting now
I'm getting the truth this is what I was
getting out earlier but you know nothing
really impresses him right you know and
that real Scottish you know bring people
down that were successful um you know
whereas my mom is the opposite right
gushing and everything's
amazing and so it's like you you kind of
strike the balance between both uh but
they create your driving force to
understand how to find positivity in any
situation
[Music]
mhm where does happiness come from and
how do we get more of it if you find
yourself grappling with these questions
then my ation with Arthur Brooks from
episode 683 is going to be your jam
Arthur is a professor at Harvard
Business School and the bestselling
author of build the life you want here
is a clip from that
conversation most people say I want to
be happy to begin with that's the wrong
goal because you can't be happy
happiness is not a destination happiness
is a direction you can't be I mean for
somebody to be truly happy would mean
that you would need to eliminate the
parts of your life that are literally
keeping you alive like your negative
emotions you need anger and sadness and
disgust and and you need grief and you
need all these things um to stay alive
and and deal with the world so pure
happiness shouldn't be the goal but
getting happier is a legitimate goal for
everybody the biggest mistake that
people make is thinking that it's a
feeling and chasing a feeling happiness
is not a feeling it has feelings
associated with it but feelings of
Happiness are really evidence of
Happiness sort of the smell of dinner is
the evidence of dinner it's not dinner
itself that would be a very
disappointing dinner if it were just you
know the smell of Thanksgiving you know
shoot it into the air and then then that
that's that's what chasing feelings is
really like it's incredibly ephemeral
and it's a terrible thing to live that
way to live trying you know hoping that
tomorrow you'll feel a different way and
so the first freeing thing is that
number one don't worry about being
happier let's work on getting happier
it's a project that's number one very
empowering and number two is that it's
not a feeling it's something that you
really can work on it's something you
it's a skill you can really get better
at so that's the Prelude to you know how
people see it wrong and how they can be
encouraged to see it correctly and and
start to get better at then the whole
question becomes okay it's not a feeling
what is it and that's a big that's a a
controversy in in the world of social
psychology and social science in general
even Neuroscience what is happiness but
as a functional definition you find that
people who have the most well-being in
their lives have balance and abundance
across three things sort of macro
nutrients so the protein carbohydrates
and fat of Happiness are enjoyment
satisfaction and purpose those are the
three things that people actually need
and none of those things is as simple as
it sounds each one has a literature of
of of science behind it and has
protocols and habits that we can all
pursue and get better at so the great
news is that every single person
watching us can get happier and the
better news is we know what they can
work on to get happier but they need the
knowledge right so this idea that
happiness we can we can have a debate on
how we particularly Define what it is
but the truth of the matter is that
that's less important than this idea
that it is evidence or uh something that
comes about as a result of these three
macro nutrients that we should all
pursue that will yeah as as a kind of
way of life it's not one something you
do once it's something that you
incorporate into the way that you're
living your life correct right um that
will time and again produce that
sensation of Happiness however ephemeral
or fleeting it may be but with some
regularity it will build more of that
into your life exactly right exactly
right and these are skills that you can
get better at this is the you know the
best news of all but you have to know
what they are and and it's not
straightforward part of re not when you
say enjoyment as one of these that that
could create some confusion it can and
and the biggest confusion is especially
for people that are really into
improving themselves through knowledge
that they can get on you know the rich
role podcast for example is they might
make the mistake of thinking that
enjoyment is pleasure and it's
absolutely not pleasure is a is a limic
phenomenon it's an ancient phenomenon
it's a signal to you that something is
going to be good for your survival or
passing on your genes but the pursuit of
pleasure will not bring you happiness it
will bring you addiction
that's as sure as we're sitting here is
what it will do and the reason is
because it's a fleeting thing it's a
fleeting sensation if you hit the lever
and hit the lever you'll change your
brain chemistry to get really really
good to bring you that pleasure and that
will give you addiction you know all
addictions are are are based in a in in
an excessive and um uh unhealthy uh
stimulation of dopamine the
neuromodulator dopamine in the human
brain so the the the reason that for
example that you know drinking too much
brings pleasure but doesn't bring
happiness is because it doesn't actually
bring enjoyment so this is the key thing
to understand enjoyment has a base in
pleasure but it adds two things it adds
people and memory so anything that you
do that brings pleasure you do Alone
look out as a rule of thumb anything
that's pleasurable that you do alone is
not going to bring you happiness you
need people involved and you need memory
which is part of your prefrontal cortex
is your executive function has to be
involved in that and and a good example
of how we understand this intuitively
you know Heiser bush has a beer
commercial they never have how a lot of
people are using budlight which is
pounding a 12pack alone in their
apartment mm that's and and the reason
that they don't advertise it that way
which is that they don't want to
advertise their product as a way to get
pleasure but not happiness they have
people drinking Bud Light with their
friends or with their family and making
a memory because it's pleasure feels
good plus people plus memory and then
you get happiness and so this is the way
to think about gambling if you're going
to gamble this is the way to think about
sexual activity this is the way to think
about any of these things that if it's
you know alone and compulsive becomes a
problem but if it's sociable and it
creates memory it actually can be
enhance your happiness everybody who and
I don't drink alcohol you don't drink
alcohol I don't know how to drink
alcohol in a normal way why because I
started drinking alcohol when I was 13
14 years old and it was nothing but
solitary pleasure and I never learned
how to make it into a source of
enjoyment that's the reason that it
became a problem is because I was never
able to use it in a responsible way
where it could enhance my
happiness we got a lot more to come but
first all right people enter Brad
stalberg a writer and a coach
specializing in human performance Brad
made his fourth appearance on the
podcast this year delivering a powerful
primer on embracing transformation how
to cultivate resilience and how to adapt
to an everchanging
[Music]
World We tend to think of change as
something that happens to us or these
singular events when in reality we are
just always in conversation with change
and because we think of it as these
singular events we often relate to
change is something that happens to us
instead of something that we're in
conversation with with mhm and the
kernel of the idea I know you said you
want to get into it so I'm sure we will
in more detail um early covid just
article after article with the headline
when are things going to get back to
normal and it struck me that back to
normal is probably never going to happen
MH and um then I did what I do which is
I got really curious and I started
looking at the literature on how we
think about change and um realize these
two competing models of homeostasis and
allostasis
and we spend a lot of time thinking
about homeostasis and that's kind of the
um conventional prevailing model but
it's not necessarily the best fit one so
explain that that difference between
homeostasis and allostasis what is that
concept so homeostasis is this notion
that living systems crave stability and
anytime that they are confronted with
change or disruption they try to get
back to that stability as swiftly as
possible mhm so it describes a PN of
order or stability then some sort of
disorder or change and then back to
order right and that was sort of the
prevailing I don't know if theology is
the right word but kind of operating
system for how things work how
biological systems operate how
ecosystems operate for a long time
that's right since the mid 1800s uh a
scientist named Walter Cannon coined it
and science was very different in the
1800s I mean we're talking like prev
vaccines germ theory of disease um yeah
it stuck with us for a very long time
and it's really encroached upon not just
scientific or biological change but how
we think about so many different changes
uh including habit change I mean if you
Google homeostasis and change you'll see
like this is why losing weight is hard
this is why starting a habit is hard
this is why stopping a bad habit is hard
but then about 20 years ago
researchers re evaluated this model of
homeostasis and they said actually when
you look at really vital thriving
systems they don't follow this path of
order disorder order yes systems want to
be stable but that stability is achieved
somewhere new by changing and allostasis
is a process of order disorder reorder
and what's fascinating is if you look at
the emology of these words homo means
same and stasis means standing so
having the same standing by being the
same and Alo means variable so
allostasis is literally translated into
stability through change and I think
that it's this beautiful double meaning
where the way that we're stable is by
being able to change to some extent so
we stay stable not by resisting change
but by changing extrapolating on that
idea you can't help but think about
Evolution like if it was order disorder
order there would be no Evolution it is
only through the reordering that you see
the adaptation really so what you're
saying basically is there's a status quo
there's an intervening set of
circumstances and then there's an
adaptation to those circumstances that
hopefully creates a new version of that
impermanent
homeostasis that's it yeah and and
evolution is I think change on the
grandest scale that we know of and you
see allostasis playing out at the
species level but then you zoom in on an
given individual M and you think about
personal Evolution or how we grow over
the course of our life and it's very
much the same like we're constantly
somewhere in that cycle of order
disorder reorder and even if you lived
in um in like a container that was
completely shielded from the elements
you're still aging so like I think it is
really helpful to think of your identity
like a
house and within that house you want to
have some different rooms and and you
might have the room of parent of partner
of creative of athlete of employee um
you name it it's okay to go spend all
your time in one room for a season of
your life maybe even a few right I mean
a couple books ago right I co-wrote the
passion Paradox it's literally in the
subtitle like a guide to going Allin so
it's you don't have to balance your time
across all five of those rooms or six of
those rooms but I think it is just so
important to make sure that those other
rooms are available to you so that when
[__] hits the fan in the room that
you're in mhm you can go step into
another room and this isn't just my
hypothesis in the literature it's called
self-complexity and individuals that
have higher levels of self-complexity
tend to be more resilient to
change one of the world's most
compelling and iconic public figures the
singular Arnold Schwarzenegger shared
how he reached the Pinnacle of success
in three very different careers we also
discussed why he believes adversity
breeds character as well as lessons from
his book be
useful I think that one of the things
that you learn in sports is that if you
just get stuck in your own training
routine and not learn from other people
that you would never become a
champion and uh so open-mindedness was
very important to me and so I think like
I said in my book I learned a lot of my
lessons from Sports and to me that kind
of like and having people like a Freddy
gerle uh that Mentor that talked about
open-mindedness and learning from others
to me was always kind of like learning
new things and uh being able to uh the
more you become a celebrity to be able
to use that celebrity power for
something positive for something good
and so to me it was I I learned the more
I opened up my mind the better it was
there was a guy by the name of Vince
geranda you maybe have heard of him
since you're a fitness fanatic yourself
uh that it's he had a gym over in in the
valley Vince's gym and I saw him doing
an exercise a triceps exercise and I I I
looked at him I said what are you doing
he says this is for the outside tricep
that splits the one head from the other
no and I said this looks like some kind
of a Mickey Mouse exercise Jesus Christ
doesn't look like some heavy lift of
some sort and he says we just try it so
I said to myself well the way you try it
the way I tried it in those days was I
would do an exercise 40 sets of 20 reps
so I was lying there on the bench on my
back taking this dumbill going like this
20 times and take it over to this side
do the same thing over here here same
through this arm back and forth back and
forth like this the next day this muscle
here was just jumping all over the place
so I realized he was absolutely correct
I never ever thought of that there's
actually a specific muscle we always
know about sculpting your body that you
add more chest or more calus muscles or
obliques or some biceps and some more
but that you can actually dissect into a
specific part of the three muscle that's
why it's called triceps there's three
muscles there and one separates the
bicep from the tricep and makes it
appear not that measurement Wise It's
bigger but makes it appear much larger
so I was doing that and uh that exist
from that point on and it just it was I
said to myself if I wouldn't have
listened to him I would have never
learned that exercise but I listened to
him I first said him said brushed it off
and said Mickey Mouse ex I said no no no
let's just try it before we kind of like
come to conclusion and true enough so
you learn from those kind of experiences
and you then apply there's a rule with
everything and so that's why I was
always uh rather more hungry for more
information more hungry for listening
rather than talking you know how do you
think about the way that our culture now
uh thinks about mental
health uh and and our relationship with
this idea of of
powerlessness I think that in
general I think what the
book is trying to do is to say to
people you need to
work on
yourself if you just try to be
pampered and if you're trying to be
soft and if you're trying to be the
victim and all of you're not going to go
anywhere
we need to get
stronger we need to get ballsier we need
to get
tougher we need to not be afraid of
failure we got to go and do the work we
got to face adversity adversity breeds
character the strength and fighting and
resistance does not only make the muscle
grow but it makes also your head grow
makes you a stronger person we have to
be willing to go through hardship
through suffering through pain through
crying periods all of that stuff don't
shy away from any of that because it
just makes you stronger and I think
today lot of times our youth is so into
kind of oh let's make him feel good oh
no let's be more sensitive well I
totally agree with you to be sensitive
about things but I mean there's also a
sweet
spot can we go too
far you know it's like when some someone
says well today I just need to sleep in
I said [__] yeah you don't need to
sleep in this country was not built on
sleeping in so let's get up in the
morning and let's get on that bike and
let's do some exercise and don't even
think about it don't look at your email
or anything like this let's just get
going boom boom boom let's get going
let's start building and so that's the
idea is just not to be overly soft and
overly kind of like sensitive and
everyone is in the victim kind of thing
I just don't buy into that but you have
to understand that every person has to
be approached also differently it's like
uh the mind is just like the body I
cannot give you exactly the same
training routine that I had because your
body is different you're a much leaner
person you need kind of to do maybe
lesser reps and what this you have to
have a different diet if you want to
bulk up and all this so I have to be
aware of that that even within my family
one of my daughters had to be approached
differently than my other daughter one
son had to be approached differently
than the other son so you have to be
sensitive about those kind of things but
overall it was discipline in the house
you don't turn out that light I will
unscrew those light bulbs and you will
be going into the dark room with the age
of three and you will be scared so you
better start learning the turn off the
those lights you have someone else make
you bit okay I'm going to take the
mattress and throw it down the balcony
and then you carry it upstairs and you
make your own bed again you the things
you got to just kind of figure it out uh
you know how to do that in all but you
know it's it's it's it's it's not easy
I'm not a psychologist I'm not an expert
with this but one thing I know for sure
I can help anyone to go and be a little
bit better right and I think that's what
we want to ask we canot ask everyone to
be a genius ask everyone to be the
World's Strongest Man and all stuff but
to be better because when you're better
and when you get better then you feel
good when we improve we feel good when
we have accomplished something we feel
good and that then rubs off on
everything our nation is lonelier than
ever before and this event is so severe
the US Surgeon General vice admiral Dr V
myy labeled it an epidemic Dr Murthy
joined me in episode 784 to discuss the
physical and psychological effects of
loneliness and why it's become such a
major Public Health
crisis loneliness isn't something that's
new uh but what is new is this epidemic
of loneliness that that currently
defines our culture the statistics as
you lay them out are are quite shocking
think you say one out of every two
Americans is experiencing measurable
levels of loneliness one in two people
uh
that's more people than suffer from
diabetes like this is a huge problem
right so I guess the question I have is
how did we get here what are the
tectonic plates that have led us to this
state that we're in yeah it's the
numbers are quite shocking and you're
right that this is extraordinarily
common and as as surprising as a one and
two number is the rates of loneliness
are even higher among young people um
which surprises people who think hey
aren't they connected by technology yet
they are saying whether it's in spite of
that or in some cases because of the use
of social media the sense of connection
people feel has actually diminished so
how do we get here well several things
happen and we didn't get here overnight
either but I think that our sense of
disconnection has been building for some
time so here are a few things that
started to happen uh you know as over
the last 20 to 30 years we have become
more mobile right so we move more often
for work for
school and we often move multiple times
sometimes in a short time frame uh
whereas before that people would often
stay in the areas that they grew up in
they would um stay connected to the
people they were friends with in high
school they still lived around them uh
but as you move more communities become
more fragmented so that's sort of One
Piece the second thing that has happened
is historically going back Generations
people tended to live in extended family
environments and so you know not that
that was all simple or that it was all
good you know but uh but those
environments you know more often than
not ensure that people were connected
with others uh the shift away from uh
you know from extended families has been
one more factor I that's LED people to
live in smaller and smaller circles but
the other factors I think that are
important here is that we've also seen
over the last half century a significant
decline in participation in the
community organizations that used to
bring people together uh particularly
Faith organizations uh but also service
organizations ations recreational
leagues youth leagues um these used to
bring folks together from different
walks of life um to get to know one
another to break bread together to
engage in activities together um but
that opportunity has also been lost uh
two other factors worth mentioning one
is the rise of what I think of is
convenience technology right so today if
I I can sit in my home and get groceries
delivered to me I don't really need to
go to a post office I can get most
things I need from Amazon I don't need
to to a store um my need to go out and
have interaction with other people is
dramatically lower just from a practical
standpoint um so we have lost actually a
lot of those informal loose ties if you
will but finally I think we have to look
at the phenomenon of social media itself
uh which has dramatically transformed
how we interact with each other and also
has transformed how many people see
themselves and their friendships and
this is particularly true for young
people but while there are some benefits
of social media can be helpful to get
messages out to share useful information
to share honest reflections with a large
group of people uh far off more often
than not what we're finding is that for
many people uh well I'll just tell you
what young people tell me most commonly
they tell me three things they say their
use of social media often makes them
feel worse about themselves as they're
constantly comparing themselves to
others makes them feel worse about their
friendships as they're constantly seeing
what other people are doing without them
from feeling left out but third they say
that can get off it either because these
platforms are often designed to maximize
how much time we spend on them not
necessarily the quality of time but the
quantity of time and what what is
happening especially to many young
people but frankly to many older people
as well is that that is taking time away
from other critical activities like
sleep like in-person interaction uh and
other activities that are essential for
our health and well-being so you put all
these factors together rich and what you
see is that we have become lonelier we
become more isolated and I think we've
realiz and this is not just an American
phenomenon by the way uh this is a
broader feature of modernity uh that the
UK Australia Japan and many other
countries are experiencing as well um so
we've got to recognize that uh and it
doesn't mean that we should go back to
1920 or 1930 or 1950 but what it does
mean is that we have to recognize that
if we don't consciously make rebuilding
connection
a priority in our individual lives and
in society more broadly if we don't do
that through individual actions and the
building of social infrastructure in our
communities then we will continue to see
an erosion uh of our relationships and
we'll see not only the health
consequences of loneliness which are
profound mental and physical but also
the economic and the National Security
implications of loneliness which make us
more prone to division and to
polarization so we've got to make that
choice and right now it feels like the
choice is being made for us that we're
steeped in this information environment
that's extraordinarily negative that's
telling us everything is broken about
the world that nobody can be trusted and
that everyone is only out for themselves
we've got to turn that off and tune in
uh to what's actually happening in our
communities and choose again love I
always say that every decision that we
make we can ask ourselves a question am
I making this decision out of love or
out of fear and if we choose love as
often as we
can then we'll build a kind of life that
feels good for us that's good for our
communities that our kids can be proud
of that will help create the world that
ultimately future Generations
[Music]
need 2023 marked the return of comedian
and fellow podcast host Pete Holmes in
episode 788 we talked about everything
from spirituality to Comedy creativity
Consciousness fatherhood
and the many disorientations of midlife
here's a glimpse into our equal parts
hilarious and thought-provoking
exchange there are some truths so big
they can only be told with lies uh that
that's a cute way of saying metaphor is
the only language we have to speak of
God um and I say this in the special
it's Richard Roy as well metaphor means
always true sometimes really happen cuz
with interesting about the Bible one of
the weird things about that text is that
its metaphor overlain with history you
know what I mean it's like metaphorized
history and we don't know where the line
is uh you know opinions vary but when
you're trying to and if you've taken
psychedelics and that was a huge part of
my appreciation of metaphor but when
you're trying to talk about the
ineffable metaphor isn't just as close
as you can get it's the only way to do
it it it it stirs you and moves you in
in a way that it's the truth of it is
it's true in the way that energy moves
in the world it's it's true in the way
the patterns of the universe are
reflected in the story because you can
tell a story and it's [__] like you
know but the the metaphors and the myths
that stick with us they'll they'll rock
you and you hear it and you your Skin's
lit on fire and and we're [__] stuck
with numbers and measurements and
recipes like get the [__] out of here
none of that [__] helps you when your
heart is broken none of them none of
that helps when your grandfather is
dying or or when a baby is born like
poetry is similar it we we get that [__]
out of here until your wife leaves you
then William Blake gets a lot more
important but we've become interested
and or or fascinated or obsessed with
the quantifiable and the reproducible
and the and the and the material and
it's like okay but you know we're
leaving a
lot in our rear view that That's
essential yeah you know it's so
emasculated in our culture well because
you can't have sex with it and you can't
sell it really you know what I mean so
like what are you doing I'll tell you
what you're doing is you're feeling more
at home in the universe this is my whole
thing the fact that it's like cowardly
to go to therapy like like the people
where I'm from if you say you're in
therapy they're it's
like I'm like is there anything more
cowardly than not facing your demons
like who's the coward I I might just be
sitting on a couch but I'm going into
the cave where the Vader mask cuts open
and it's my face like that's the hero
and and it's easy to do the same with
spirituality be like it's a bunch of
Lies yeah Santa Claus isn't real great
but what is the story of Santa what is
the point what is done in secret is
rewarded or whatever it might be I don't
know man
literalism is a [__] terrible body to
snuggle up to in your bed at night and
and the warm bosom of myth has kept
human beings alive and by the way don't
get me started every video game every
movie it's all right there sure every
avenger get the [__] out of here
and and Joseph Campbell is like the
gateway drug yeah for a lot of people
especially in this town that's right
well he changed my life he said God is
is a metaphor for a mystery that
absolutely transcends all categories of
human thought including being and
non-being so I that I could get on board
with that's a God I I feel like that's a
god anyone could agree on it's a
metaphor meaning God is not an old man
in the sky an old man in the sky is a
metaphor for a metaphor God itself is a
metaphor and a metaphor for that
metaphor is an old man on the sky old
he's old older than you he's been around
in the sky has a higher perspective than
you on a throne he's powerful sh these
just ways of understanding a force right
but that's a metaphor for God which is
itself a metaphor for a mystery
something unknown is doing something we
know not what right that we so this is
also in my special Barry Taylor the road
manager for ACDC says God is the name of
the blanket we put over the mystery to
give it a shape God is in the name of
give it a shape and I say shouldn't we
have learned this in church why am I
learning this from the road manager for
ACDC and it's not about solving the
mystery it's about appreciating the fact
that it is a mystery and we want to talk
about it and more than that we want to
commune with it and to know that we have
to give it some sort of symbol Carl
Young says we're not transformed by
ideas we're transformed by symbols this
is why the crucified Christ is still a
hot story yes but how do you like I'm
I'm I'm thinking of the person who's
listening to this who hasn't had their
Reckoning yet they haven't hit their
pain moment like how do you communicate
to that person or how do you get
somebody to you know connect with that
possibility in their own
life that's why I'm not putting that
question off to Carle but when people
email me you know on social or something
and they're like I can't it's Nails on a
chalkboard you say I'm God's child it's
Nails on a chalkboard or or Jesus or
Buddha or anything the the baggage of
that people are carrying around from
whatever experiences they had yeah I
relate to that I had that and people
like first of all Joseph Campbell who's
just gonna say it's a story and that's
great but then at Carle who's all just
the sacrament of the present moment and
when you start getting naked I was just
talking about this today on my own
podcast I was like why are Adam and Eve
naked it's because they're they don't
they're not clothed in the ego in the
story just pure here and when you drop
through practic through reading that
book whatever it might be and you start
getting familiar with who are you like
you're you're wearing a space suit you
know right and we start thinking we're
the suit this is ramdas ramdas would say
I go hello rich and you go hello Pete
you're a comedian I go yes and we are
Americans I remember I was in Italy I
saw a ladybug and I was like this
ladybug has no idea it's
Italian has no idea it's it tell you how
many [__] things are we carrying
around and who are you when you drop
them and which of those things are
undroppable I don't I don't think there
are any that are undroppable and Raman
Mahari has this great thing where he
goes when you're stoking the fire of
your own awareness the last thing you
get the fire going the last thing you
throw in is the stick you were staking
the fire with you can even drop your
practice all of it can go cuz you're
zero you're your smallest most
irreducible undividable
you that's that's the part that knows
this whether or not you Vibe with this
language but there's a part of you and I
would also recommend Rupert Spyro if you
if you uh read being aware of being
aware which is a very short book and
every chapter says the same you can just
read the first chapter read I know
Richard Roar but I haven't I haven't
read that book rert is a beautiful non-u
teacher but he will just go like what is
it that's aware of your
experience and he's like that's nobody's
asking that he he says we're like the
screen of a
movie and everybody gets so caught up in
the content of the movie just like we do
when we watch a movie that you forget
you're looking at a screen but you're
the screen it's not colored or changed
in any meaningful way by the Light
that's on it right now I'm so oh I'm on
a podcast all this I'm a screen what is
the screen what what dis dist is an
illusion like this sound is farther than
this it's all happening on the screen of
my awareness and the the the the
additional delusion to that is that it's
all happening in our head right but that
is also just an appearance in
Consciousness that's what I so science I
I'm a pro science person obvious I I
hope I don't have to say that but
science will say I saw a TED Talk where
they're like reality is a agreed upon uh
group hallucination and that's really
right on with a lot of mystical
traditions this is Maya or this is play
or whatever you want to say but they'll
say it originates in the brain so that's
like you and I are having a dream and I
hold up a a ring box and I go this dream
is coming from this box like why would a
part of the dream be a reliable source
of the dream what the [__] do we know
about the mind you know what I'm saying
so we're going it originates in the
amydala of the blah blah blah that's
also you can't remove the Observer it's
it's influencing and part of and
drenched in the obser you are the
Observer right the idea that there is a
self right that is observing right is is
a further illusion right and that that
self resides somewhere inside your head
right and and that's hard like it takes
practice to disabuse yourself because
it's
so entrenched in our deep rooted
attachment to what is
[Music]
real as a lifelong Star Trek fan hosting
Sir Patrick Stewart was a dream that did
not disappoint in episode 785 when the
Beloved icon of stage and Screen graced
the podcast for a vulnerable exchange
covering his extraordinary life as well
as his new Memoir making it
so um you've lived just an absolutely
extraordinary life and you know you did
a wonderful job with the book it's it's
wildly entertaining it's a very
difficult book to put down the stories
are just absolutely legendary so well
done in that regard I I love it and I
know you're about to embark on quite the
book tour so you're going to be doing a
lot of Media stuff um I guess you know
I'm curious about what it is that you
want people to
take from the book but also just your
life like what is instructive about the
experiences that you've had the lessons
that you've learned as you reflect back
as an 83 yearold man on what's important
what's not and and and and maybe even a
guiding principle or two that we could
incorporate into our own
lives well they they come down to things
that I am still working on um and it's
awkward being a leading
actor on television and film um but um
being brave
being
open
being sensitive to other people tuning
into them becomes more and more and more
important to me and I find that in the
close friends that I have that is their
relationship with me too and it's a
wonderful wonderful
experience
um
I I wish I could go back
there are things I would like to say to
my
parents and my brothers both of
them that I never
said and that makes me very very
sad that I never told
them what they gave me but this gives
you an an opportunity to at least say it
does publicly yeah it kind of does yes
yeah I
mean my first draft of this book was
over 700 pages uhhuh and it's now about
440 so people are saying so what are you
going to write next and I said no no no
no no there's no next this is it it and
then the other day I thought hm um
well maybe I could find that draft
that's got 350 words in it that are on
in my book the director's cut like the
director's cut yeah yeah um to your
point that was beautifully shared thank
you uh there's a a section in the book
that that I found quite moving which was
about your relationship with
vulnerability as an actor and how that's
a tool and a vehicle for unlocking truth
but also as as a um a way of being in
the world right the the the power that
comes with allowing yourself to be
vulnerable on stage but also with the
people that you care about yes yes yes
that's
um perhaps the primary objective in my
life now to be vulnerable with those you
care about
yes
yes there are
many for me
great resonances about being an
actor and one of the strongest
is the people I encounter finding that
there were in the world other young
people and some of them significantly
older who um felt the same kind of
isolation that I
felt and yet in the company of actors
there was an almost
intuitive uh connection that was made
between us um and I was 12 years old
when I first was dumped into a uh a
large group of actors on a a course that
was run it was a brand new course run by
the West riding County Council in new
Yorkshire and um the minimum age was 14
and it was in my headmaster's office
that I met a man called Gerald Tyler
he's in the book and he had come to say
that the um the County Council were
going to run an 8-day
a theater course a residential theater
course by that it meant we had uh Camp
beds to lie on in School classrooms but
nevertheless from the moment that I
arrived there I was in the
company of people like me now some of
them were highly educated I mean I got a
big crush on a girl who was at grammar
school but it didn't work out I was at
secondary modern School
no no um and and yet it was our love of
acting performing of plays scripts texts
um uh being in front of an audience
which Never Scared me ever at all and
there was a reason for
this um one of my first attractions to
acting was that I could forget about
Patrick Stewart right that was my next
question how much of this aside from
finding like-minded people in this tribe
of young artist how much of it was an
escape from your own life or the uh
opportunity to step outside who you were
and just become somebody altogether
different as a defense mechanism and not
having to deal with whatever pain is
kind of lingering in your
subconscious you uh expl it perfectly
that's exactly how it was to not be
Patrick Stewart if only for a few hours
a week was such a relief to explore
being someone other than myself with a
different background I mean the first
role that I played other than this um
this thing that we' done about the
history of Yorkshire and murfield where
I grew up
um was uh a comedy called
the happiest days of your life you may
have encountered it very occasionally it
crops up in the very
occasionally and um it was all set in a
private boy School a rather exclusive
private boy school and it was wartime
and a private girl school had been um
found places in the school so there were
now boys and girls playing there and I
played a character you see I remember
his name called hop Croft Miner he had
an older brother who is hop coft and um
and it was such a joy to be playing an
upper class child even though I
struggled with the accent I didn't
really have um a proper received
pronunciation ACC until I was 15 or 16
but I was learning I was and and
sometimes it made people laugh when they
heard me speak because it sounded so
portentous and you know um so becoming
someone
else that was the main attraction yeah
and I could forget who Patrick Stewart
was maintaining mobility and finding
meaningful movement practices were Hot
Topics in 2023 ones that I explored not
only in a movement master class but also
with movement experts and built to move
authors Kelly and Juliet starett they
joined me in episode 764 to give us easy
ways to change sedentary habits and
integrate more movement into your daily
[Music]
life there's a lot of confusion around
what you mean when you talk about
Mobility so let's just clarify that and
I kind of want to build on that to get
into the various you know principles
that form the framework of this book and
your
philosophy well I mean I'll start and
maybe take a swing take swing at this I
think I mean at this point you ought to
be able to Define it right um to us uh
you know Mobility is is really the
ability to be able to move freely
through your environment and do the
things you want to be able to do with
your body whatever those things may be
now we we offer a lot of tools which we
we call mobilizations which are things
you can do to help improve your mobility
and range of motion but you know to us
at the highest level it's a it's the
ability to move freely ideally without
pain or at least minimizing pain and be
able to do the things you love to do and
if I added a how did I do pretty pretty
good for an attorney I uh you've been in
the game for a minute I can tell I would
add your body everyone agrees that your
shoulder should be able to do certain
things and that your spine should be
able to do certain things and your hips
should bu certain things every physician
every orthopedic surgeon every physical
therapist we all agree how much shoulder
is normal how much your ankle should be
able to
move the problem is that we don't give
people benchmarks for what is normative
or what you should be able to do and our
lives sometimes don't ask us of that and
so suddenly when we have pain or a
problem that range of motion is never
part of the conversation about hey I see
that your steeling wheel doesn't go all
the way to the left left let's just make
sure that you can you know the pilots
where they take off you know they check
to make sure everything's working right
so we could also Define mobility as do
you have your native range of motion and
can you control that native range of
motion so are you a skilled person and
what Juliet said is all of that is
important but really what is it you want
to do in your world and environment and
how do you want to express this body
that's the most important thing and I
think that's where we got in the weeds
you know yeah hip range motion is
important yeah yeah yeah but if it
prevents you from doing something or
you're having pain and that's also
conjoined with the fact that you don't
have access to that range maybe that's
the reason you should care well and like
let me just give you one example like if
you just asked anyone on the street like
do you care about your hip range of
motion they're going to be like no why
would I care about that um but but as an
example we were recently talking to a
friend of ours who has a four-month-old
baby and has both sets of parents
visiting and they his parents are like
in their mid-60s so um you know not that
much older than than us and they uh his
mother is able to get up off get up and
down off the ground and sit with the
baby but his mother-in-law can't get
down onto the ground or up off of the
ground and so can't sit on the floor and
play with the
grandchild and that's one of those
things that you don't think about until
it's like a use it or lose it kind of
thing but like that right there is hip
range of motion so you may not care
athletically about hip range of motion
because you're not trying to run faster
or lift more weights or you know
whatever an athlete might need to care
about hip range of motion for but you
know most people would say man do you
know do you want to be able to sit on
the floor and play with your grandchild
when you have one and they'd be like yes
I do um and so you know that's one of
the reasons why people should care about
their hip range range of motion right I
I I feel that humans are not very good
at casting their gaze that far into the
future though especially like it's not
25 you 20 like yeah you're just like
I'll deal with that when I can going to
happen to me especially with an elite
athlete like forget about it right so
the barrier to being able to you know
convince somebody that these things are
important has to be it's like a high bar
for you right to to like communicate
with people like hey you know we can
talk about longevity how long do you
want to live what is it that you want to
be able to do when you're 80 and 90 Etc
but when you're 30 even in in your 40s
and and you're essentially painfree or
you don't have some kind of injury uh
that's you you know that that's a
challenge like you know but it is true
that like whether it's heart disease
diabetes you know any kind of brain
degeneration similarly with our physical
bodies like these things are progressive
and if you're not working on this stuff
far in advance of those aging years um
you're going to have a problem but if
you do undergo you know you know sort of
shoulder the responsibility of of doing
these things that you guys talk about so
much you're taking out this insurance
policy to be able to do all those things
in your later years but it's just that
humans are not good at like you know
evaluating the cost benefit analysis of
these sorts of things and our
environment gives us a lot of cues or
guides us into poor decisions I just I
think New York Times had an article just
recently about how some of our Foods
hijack our brain chemistry right our
modern Foods zamis we just think oh
they're so good so here's a story I was
a young physio student watching the
cardiac catheter lab and uh I'm watching
a a really wealthy kid a wealthy man in
San Francisco and his whole family is
outside he has three beautiful daughters
which I can start to like put myself in
his shoes has this amazing wife Killer
Law Practice he's rich in every
definition of the term he's one life and
he's in there having three stance put in
his heart and he's overweight and what I
thought in that moment was if this guy
has every resource and every reason to
live and it's still that hard to change
and to make these things to keep himself
alive with his family what what recourse
does an average person mortal person
without his resources have and really
that was a kind of a shocker and I think
if I'd videoed the two women you know
putting in the cath like chain smoking
you know like as a matter of fact that
may have showed him that video maybe
that would have changed his behavior but
you know it's really difficult to sort
of untangle what seems like the biggest
gordian knot in your life where do I go
especially since sometimes we don't see
the results right away yeah so when when
when talking about mobility and movement
you know how do you diagnose somebody's
Mobility like everybody you know you
guys have like this superpower you can
like look at somebody just sitting or
standing or walking and be like oh I see
10 things wrong with like what's
happening there like most people don't
have that ability and don't think about
that kind of stuff uh you know the
average person if they're painfree is
going to say well this is not I can walk
and I can get up and sit down and all
that kind of stuff so where does one
begin to try to self diagnose and
understand um their own uh Mobility
capacity limitations and and what they
should be focused on working on well in
this book we we literally identify five
areas where we think that if people just
kept an eye on it like just kept an eye
on it a Vital sign just yeah we call
them Vital Signs these 10 things yeah we
have these 10 vital signs but we
specifically chose the word Vital sign
because it it started coming up more and
more in the pandemic actually everyone
was like tracking all these Vital Signs
like their seo2 and you know obviously
everybody knows that 120 over 80 is like
okay blood pressure and if you go over
that it's something you should keep an
eye on and so that's why we we thought
well if if regular people can keep an
eye on a Vital sign like blood pressure
then why can't there be some movement
specific or health specific Vital Signs
and so um you know obviously the human
body is the most complicated thing in
the known universe um but we really
tried to boil it down to a few areas of
range of motion we thought people should
keep an eye on or that we considered to
be Vital Signs and we do have these
simple tests in the book um that people
can just do once and sort of say okay
this is where I'm at you know this is
something I need to keep an eye on this
is something I'm doing great at and and
you know and then the things we suggest
for people to work on them we think
we've suggested you know things that
they can literally do like while they're
watching Netflix at night or while
they're still sitting at their office
like we've really tried to make it so
that you don't have to go to the 1hour
mobility B class and you know journal in
the morning in order to get in order to
get these things
done one of the most acclaimed
filmmakers of his generation the great
Jud appow Grace the podcast to discuss
his fascinating perspective on film
making on storytelling on creativity and
just tons more so here is a slice of
that
exchange you the other person that was a
important mentor to me was dve David
milch who created Deadwood and
co-created NYPD Blue with Steven botko
and he was another one that you know
everybody talks I mean reveres him as a
genius you know he he taught at Yale but
he also you know had a lot of issues
with addiction and and gambling and you
know he was one of those people that
would he would lay on the ground there'd
be a microphone on the ground and he
would dictate the show and would wait
around well he channeled the show and he
he believed he used to say
uh inspiration comes to prepared souls
and his whole thing was about that
connection can you open yourself up and
be so present and available that the
creativity
comes and to trust that and I I learned
so much from him about that or you know
one of the David milch things is to you
know to to just start writing you know
he he always says
uh you can't think yourself into writing
but you can write yourself into
thinking so just start and it'll it'll
just come and so that was a a real
lesson for me you know like there ways I
could be better at this that's why when
you get back to you know self-help you
know I'm I'm always looking for
something that will make me
you know open up in some way heal in
some way learn something that will make
me more efficient and and sometimes I'm
drowning in self-help because I just
read and listen to too much that creates
its own paralysis yes yeah because I'm a
hoarder a bit so I'll I'll listen to too
much but with this I just said okay this
is this is really simple just get your
ass in the
chair don't be disrup amazement at it at
it actually working yeah because you go
like how creative am I have any jokes
left in this brain and to see it
happen uh was really rewarding and made
me think oh maybe I can do three more
times this year how do you how do you
balance the collaborative aspect of the
the creation and writing process versus
that like ass in a chair alone at
home what is the Jour you know what is
the daily you know do you set it up with
a schedule well once the script is done
then I just send it to everybody and
just go what do you think what do you
think and then it's some point I'll sit
alone and you know over with a writer's
assistant and just rewrite it and then I
try to read it out loud and then then I
can watch it like a movie and see if it
works for me as a movie and then rewrite
it then read it out loud again and then
at some point if someone will let me
make it we go into rehearsals and then
it changes a lot once the actors bring
their stuff right into it how do you
know when you're when you have an idea I
think I asked you this earlier but like
that that you know it's like once you
commit to an idea there's a long road
ahead right um is there like something
does something light up in your brain
where you're like this is it or this is
the thing like is that an instinct or uh
you have an instinct but then you just
keep like telling it to people and so
you're like if they like it you yeah it
seem funny and it's just like a movie
about like guy gets girl pregnant and he
hangs out with all his Stone friends and
he's nightmare but she wants to see if
maybe he could be a good boyfriend and
you know and then you then you start
showing the outline to some friends and
you you're looking for some
reinforcement that you're not in a crazy
Place uhuh and then at some point you
think am I really G to do this okay
maybe I I'll write five pages let me
just see if it comes to life and then
usually you go oh yeah this seems funny
does it start generally with a conceit
for you or with a a person like a
character like oh this this person what
would this person what Adventure would
this guy go
on uh I mean each each time is different
but I I like working from some very
passionate idea or truthful idea you
know when Leslie and I uh you know we're
at the hospital having our second uh our
um second child just everything went
wrong uh other than she's beautiful and
healthy but like the doctor was mean was
mean the other doctor just didn't show
up just left town to go to a bar mitzvah
and I I just took notes that night I was
like this is so crazy how weird this
night is so in the back of my head I'm
like there's probably a way to tell this
story and then you back into it you know
eventually uh you know with with Pete
Davidson with the king of sattin Island
we had worked on a different idea for a
while and then usually it it you just
say what should we really be writing
about and then it just comes out like
are you willing to explore what we
probably should explore and Pete was and
so then started writing that version
yeah yeah yeah yeah um the like knowing
when you know it's time to pull the
thread a little bit further versus
moving on and it's really hard to start
a script for me because I think one of
the things I always have to get over is
by by writing I'm finding out if I'm
terrible
so it's very easy to not write because
if I don't write I won't find out if I'm
bad do you still go to war with yourself
in that way though I think so I think
it's subtle but it's just just
because there's just a little there's a
critical voice that you you are always
wrestling with that basically says just
don't do it just go watch TV like you
don't have to suffer through this and to
try to turn it into a pleasurable
experience I'm still almost in
hyperventilation or anxiet
most of the time I'm actually writing
I'm
just my my breath get short I'm so
nervous and I'm trying to like open a
spigot and I have to relax to let it
come out but there's just a weird part
of me that's just scared scared it's
gonna be bad scared I'm gonna that like
Steven pressfield resistance ex warart
kind of thing it's totally that and and
that's what the flo thing helped me with
which is you know I toss it all I don't
have to I can throw out all the I can
throw out all the work today just just
trust it might be there might be
something good like if you I wrote this
script kind of fast and I just said I'm
gonna write straight through to the end
I'm not even going to reread yesterday's
Pages till I get to the end uhuh and
then I got to the end and then I started
reading it and I was like I don't even
remember writing almost any of like I
remember the story but the language and
the jokes and I was really pleasantly
surprised by it but I I just forced
myself to to just go to you know that
part of my imagination and just follow
it wherever it led me and that's not how
I always wrote I think I was more
methodical and I just thought maybe I'll
just kind
of you know go into the trans and see
what bubbles up make it sort of like
morning Pages no Stakes exactly and I
did those I mean the the Julie Cameron
artist way you know I I did that in the
early 90s yeah think I started that in
90 when did that book come
out 97 98 I mean I could have done that
in the no it was early no because I did
in early 90s yeah yeah yeah you're right
yeah I could have even done it late 80s
but you know so that idea of morning
Pages just write don't judge just
whatever comes out it doesn't matter
which was also David milch exercise
where he said to get your creative
juices going for two weeks right for 20
minutes a day print it and then tear it
up
just to get used to your brain being
creative and like the the Zen Buddhist m
sand Mandola that EXA yeah but he said
you'll you'll open up you know that part
of your brain and it'll fire up and I've
never done that but I understand what
he's not being precious not being too
attached there's it's like having a baby
like suddenly your body knows how to
make a
baby right like your whole life is not
making a baby then one day like this
machine builds itself and you have a
baby well is a part of your brain or
your mind that you could turn on and it
builds itself to be creative
yeah there might not be anyone better to
close out 2023 than Olympic runner
award-winning writer poet filmmaker and
friend Alexi papis who joined me to
discuss evolution self-belief
how to find the courage required to
blaze your own path and the power of
finding joy in the journey here is a
powerful clip from our
conversation oh glop can you talk about
glp yeah so glop is my favorite chapter
in the book and it represents a
knowledge that I gained since writing
bravy which was a fun thing to like
update what I knew in the world and glop
is just theide idea that uh
scientifically when caterpillars become
butterflies they go into a crysalis and
they don't just Sprout wings but they
are actually reduced down to a liquid
form complete in total liquid called
unscientifically glop and then they
become a butterfly and what I identified
with so strongly is that when I'm going
through change when any of us are going
through
change we might be reduced down to our
lowest goop State we might not feel
great and that's not a bad thing and
anytime I've felt like I was glp I
usually try to revert back and become a
caterpillar again and put myself back
together but to look at science as
inspiration I think is really empowering
because you can celebrate glp and decide
to move forward and become a butterfly
and humans are unlike caterpillars in
that we can choose to stay caterpillar
forever and we do feel the pain of Glop
Hood so caterpillars are unconscious in
their crysalis but we are not so I think
the metaphor and the chapter is
important to me
because we should feel that glp is good
and if you're feeling like glop you can
celebrate it as a
non-negotiable stage that you have to go
through to become something else yeah
yeah and you can print it on a shirt and
say I'm glp and wear it around like a
prideful label which if you haven't done
already you probably are doing I put it
on a sweatshirt when I was Glo but no
it's fun because uh kids uh people
should tell kids you can't predict your
life it will always surprise you and
that
change is is hard in in a way that is
actually like
normal you know yeah that's really
important I mean and that that goes to
your reflex towards like actionable
tools to use as opposed to feel better
or it'll be fine but like no what can I
actually do I can shake my arms out or I
can like what what is behavioral well
and also there's so much dialogue now
that says like it's okay if you don't
feel great today if you do nothing and
like I understand that I think it's
important to allow people their like
recovery days and mental health days but
like when when you are feeling like GOP
the thing that will move you forward
word is not just patience and time but
also action to become a
butterfly yeah not just wallowing in the
glob yeah exactly trying to Usher the
glob into the butterfly right yeah yeah
I think first of all all change happens
a lot slower than we think and that's
why when people see people they admire
or they read books about
transformation I think they can often be
misleading and make people think that
change is like a right turn when like
the right turn is usually happening in a
series of very very very very tiny steps
and I think big changes
happen very very
slowly um and accepting that is super
important because when I see people whip
their life around when they think they
want a big change it usually either
spirals them into depression or it's not
an effective way to actually make the
change or it leaves them with like a
tangible change but not the time to like
emotionally change with it so to evolve
as a person um so that I think is the
first thing then as far as what are you
doing so let's just say you feel like
you need to change then it's like what
is the change where am I headed what do
I do or what is the identity I want to
shift or whatever it is there's been two
things that have been helpful to me that
I'll share one was an exercise that deep
choke BR took me through in like this
small seminar that I did and I'm sure he
shared it elsewhere but basically we
were in this room and he was asking us
to ask ourselves questions without
reaching for the answer so in order
to figure out answers basically you
simply keep asking the question without
reaching for the answer so the question
might be what is my purpose right and
the goal was just to Simply keep saying
what is my purpose what is my purpose
what is my purpose without trying to
reach for the purpose cuz when we reach
we're often reaching for something like
an occupation or something in the
tangible world and it's too like
contextualized in the world but when we
just ask and like wait it was so cool
because for me what came to mind was
like hugging 21-year-old girls and
saying this is going to sound weird and
saying everything's going to be okay and
like everything going to be okay and
everything's going to be okay and like
that's not a job but it felt like a
purpose to help people feel okay and it
did feel feel accurate and that felt
like the first step was to pull our
Evolution out of the material world or
the world as we know it and to make it
more of an idea first and I think that
the next step is to figure out what you
actually do that is something that I've
drastically shifted how I approach since
being an Olympian because leading up to
the Olympics the steps there were very
clear and they were outlined by coaches
right as you said and they were tiered
based on what was most productive toward
that goal and now that the goal is less
of a tangible like I don't want to be an
Olympian anymore I want to have those
certain feelings that I shared with you
or I want to share with the world and
they're not as rooted in a job or
tangible results so how do I pick my
actions now and how do I evolve that and
I think the way I do it now is really
different Monica who is our shared
physio she was like Alexi every cell in
our body when it's happy or safe it
expands and moves toward and that's like
the feeling of having a crush on someone
or when someone's like
let's go out to Sushi and you're like
yes like that's a really it's a known
feeling that we have and she said it's
cellular and it was the feeling I was
having roller skating and she said every
cell when it's unsafe it contracts and
moves away and
that's uh what you feel when somebody
puts food in front of you that you're
allergic to or have had food poisoning
or something you know that feeling of
like I just won't eat that and she said
I want you to start thinking about your
life in terms of are these decisions
expansive or contractive to me or now I
think about it as do I have a crush on
this decision and once I started doing
that it made decisions a lot easier for
me and I started to actually evolve
without overthinking the decisions I was
making and doing things that like were
surprising to me which has been very
very
useful I hope you enjoyed this
reflection in the rear view and uh found
the these two episodes both uplifting
and inspiring I want to thank you again
for the love and all the support this
podcast truly has been just an amazing
journey and I'm beyond grateful that
you're on this journey with me I look
forward to growing and learning together
in the new year and many years ahead
links as always to all the full episodes
and the social media accounts for all
the guests excerpted today can be found
in the show notes on the episode page at
rich.com if you'd like to support the
podcast the easiest and most impactful
thing that you can do is simply
subscribe to the show on Apple podcasts
on Spotify and on YouTube sharing the
show or your favorite episodes with
friends or on social medias of course
always appreciate and finally for
podcast updates special offers on books
the meal planner and other subjects
subscribe to our newsletter which you
can find on the footer of any page at
rich.com today's show was produced and
engineered by Jason Cameo the video
edition of the podcast was created by
Dan Drake and Blake Curtis portraits by
Davey Greenberg and Jazelle Peters
graphic elements courtesy of Daniel
Solace and our theme music was created
by Tyler Patt Trapper Patt and Hari
matthys appreciate the love and support
see you next year peace plants
namaste